hello everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel
today we will be discussing about
dynamic programming paradigm in data
structure but before we begin let me
tell you guys that we have daily updates
on multiple technologies so if you are a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological advancements then
consider getting subscribe to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
now without any further audio let's get
started with the agenda for today's
discussion
we'll start this discussion by
understanding the real-life example of
dynamic programming following that we'll
go over the dynamic programming
introduction
advancing ahead we'll deal with the
dynamic programming interpretation of
fibonacci series program
here we'll cover the complexity analysis
of a simple recursive program and how we
can reduce it using dynamic programming
finally utilizing the fibonacci sequence
program will learn how dynamic
programming works
i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda
so let's get started with our first
topic that is real life example of
dynamic programming
meet rachel
she enjoys tackling puzzles because they
allow her to develop new emerging skills
in a fun way
that is why she buys puzzle books from
time to time
one day while reading through one of her
puzzle books she came across a
two-player tic-tac-toe game
she discovered one weird fact while
reading the rules of this tic-tac-toe
game
there are 2 lakh 55
168 weights to make a single move in
this puzzle game
this fact captivated her interest
encouraging her to begin playing this
tic-tac-toe puzzle game
rachel began playing this game with her
friend alex who already knew how to play
this game
as a result of her repeated failures
rachel became frustrated and started to
question how she could go on a winning
streak
after a few games rachel started
remembering the outcomes of each of her
moods which contributed to her failure
in previous games
by using those memories of her previous
games she started getting hold of the
logic behind object placement in
tic-tac-to-puzzle
rachel's ability to memorize things
helped her decide where to place an
object on the tic-tac-toe board as a
result of her hard work and commitment
to learn from her experiences she went
on a winning streak against alex
to solve complicated permutation issues
the dynamic programming paradigm employs
a similar concept of memorization
furthermore this dynamic programming
paradigm is completely based on the
philosophical idea that people who do
not remember the past are condemned to
repeat it
the dynamic programming principle states
that if we can solve smaller sub
problems then their learnings can be
memorized to solve the larger problems
this fundamental notion is acknowledged
as a foundation of dynamic programming
moving ahead let's look at the broader
picture of what is dynamic programming
dynamic programming is defined as
algorithmic paradigm that solves a given
complex problem by breaking it into
several sub problems and storing the
result of those sub problems to avoid
the computation of same sub problem over
and over again
the divide and conquer strategy is quite
similar to the dynamic programming
approach
we solve problems in each of these
paradigms by combining the solutions of
smaller sub problems however in divide
and conquer the subproblems do not
repeat themselves whereas in dynamic
programming the condition is entirely
opposite
well that means dynamic programming has
different properties than the divide and
conquer approach
and the problems which abide by those
properties can only be solved using
dynamic programming technique
so moving forward let's discover the
properties of dynamic programming
the first property that we have is
optimal substructure
if we can establish a recurrence
relation for a given problem then it is
said to have an optimal substructure
to understand this property let's have a
look at an example
the example that we are going to discuss
is called the coin change problem which
is one of the most famous dp problems in
this problem we have to construct a coin
combination with the least potential
number of coins resulting in the desired
final amount
let's say we have a limitless supply of
dollar fifty dollar twenty dollar ten
and dollar five coins and the amount for
which we need the least possible number
of coins is 85 dollars
so to formulate the solution we'll have
to traverse through all possible
permutations of coins
the most logical solution to this
problem is to add the coin of largest
value at each iteration which does not
take us past the expected amount that is
dollar 85
that means we break this problem into
several iterations by choosing the coin
of highest value at each iteration
this conversion of larger problem into
smaller sub problems is known as optimal
substructure
the next problem we have is an
overlapping subproblem
if the sub problems recur while
implementing a solution to the broader
problem then that problem is said to
have an overlapping sub problems
formulating recurring relation is the
sole technique to determine if a given
problem has an optimal sub problem or
not
to understand this better we'll have a
look at an example of a fibonacci series
program
but before we get into details of that
we would like to ask you what dynamic
programming or competitive programming
topic would you like us to address next
you can mention the topics which you
have doubts about in the comments
section below and will surely create an
exciting video about it in the next few
days so guys make sure you post a
comment with the dp or competitive
programming topics you'd like us to
cover in upcoming videos
now coming back to dynamic programming
we'll cover the mathematical
interpretation of fibonacci series
program if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
the fibonacci sequence is a group of
numbers that frequently appears in
nature
each number in this series is the sum of
two previous number that come before it
the sequence goes like 0 1 1 2 3 5 8 13
and so on
let's say the n is iterator element to
calculate consecutive fibonacci numbers
and for the first two iterations that
are 0 and 1 the resultant fibonacci
values will be simultaneously 0 and 1.
otherwise the fibonacci values will be
the sum of previous two fibonacci
numbers in the sequence
that means when the value of an iterator
element becomes 2 the consecutive
fibonacci number for it will be the sum
of previous two numbers in the sequence
that is 0 and 1 so the resulting
fibonacci number will be 1.
now when the iterator element n becomes
equal to 3 the consecutive fibonacci
numbers for 8 will become 2
for the next iteration n is equal to 4
the fibonacci values will be the sum of
1 and 2 that is 3.
when n becomes equal to 5 the resultant
fibonacci numbers will be 5 and
similarly the further numbers in
sequence can be calculated
and now if you observe the fibonacci
problem closely you'll see that the
breakdown of bigger problem is done into
smaller sub problems in previous slide
this means the fibonacci sequence
problem has an optimal substructure and
the program for the fibonacci sequence
also represents the same
this highlighted statements are
representing the recurrence relation in
our fibonacci program
now what about the overlapping sub
problems
well a problem is said to have an
overlapping sub problems if any
subproblem repeats while implementing
the solution to the broader or larger
problem
let's say we want to calculate a
fibonacci number for n is equal to 5.
the first activation record that will
enter the memory stack will be fib of 5
and to calculate the fibonacci value for
number 5 our recursive program will call
function 5 4 and 5th 3.
further to calculate fib 4 the idea will
invoke fifth three and fifth two
next it will calculate the sum of fifth
two and fib one to calculate the value
of fifth three and further it will
invoke fib one and fifth zero to
contemplate the value of fifth two now
we have generated the right side of our
call stack tree hierarchy similarly the
other missing pieces will get calculated
by the compiler with the help of
recursive calls now if you observe this
activation hierarchy you will get that
few sub problems are repeated in this
problem
the fifth three has been calculated
twice
and the fifth two has been calculated
three times in our program
this repetition of the same sub problem
while solving more significant problem
is called as overlapping subproblem
property
due to the multiple calls the
computational complexity of recursive
programs almost increases exponentially
and those calculations are entirely
unnecessary but before we understand how
to avoid all unnecessary computation
let's try to figure out the time
complexity of our fifth function
look at the time complexity relation
written over here
this says that the time taken to
calculate five n will be equal to the
time taken to calculate five of n minus
one plus time taken to calculate five of
n minus two plus the time taken to add
these numbers together
clearly for n is less than or equal to 1
the fib of n is going to be big o of 1
as we are not going to make any
recursive calls for them also
intuitively we can say that t of n will
take big o of 2 to the power n
we can contemplate this from the
recursion tree drawn on the left side
for n is equal to 5 we get a binary tree
of depth 5
for n is equal to 4 we get the binary
tree of def 4 and so on
this implies that the time complexity of
our algorithm grows at an exponential
rate and graph shown on your screens
depicts that
moving ahead we'll try to understand how
we can reduce this computational
complexity using dynamic programming
the computational complexity can be
removed by memorizing the result of sub
problems
in terms of computer science we can
refrain from doing unnecessary
computations by utilizing the memory to
store the results of sub problems in
dynamic programming we calculate the
result for sub problems and store it in
memory allocated by an operating system
when that same sub problems get
activated in our call stack we access
the memory in order to return the result
that we have calculated previously
now you must be thinking about how we
can store the result in memory
well we can store the results in two
ways the first one is memorization and
the second one is tabulation
in the case of memorization we store the
result in memory whenever we solve a
particular sub problem for the first
time
whereas in the case of tabulation we per
compute the solution in a linear fashion
and store them in a tabular format
memorization is also known as top-down
approach whereas tabulation is known as
the bottom-up approach in general these
names are assigned to these methods
based on how they approach problem
solving
the first one says result in memory
based on call stack occurrences
the second one on other hand solves the
sub problem in sequential manner
for the top down approach we maintain a
lookup table when we compute any sub
problem we store results in lookup table
and when the recurrence of this sub
problem happen we directly fetch its
value from our lookup table whereas in
the case of bottom down approach the
solution is built from the bottom most
case
in addition the memorization process is
recursive however the tabulation process
becomes iterative
if we implement the fibonacci series
program using top down approach then the
code for function 5 will look something
like this
and this one additional step
n is equal to res will do the
memorization job for us
if we develop a fibonacci sequence
program using bottom-up approach our
program will look something like this
this highlighted for loop part
calculates solution to all sub problems
from the base case
i hope you guys are clear with both
methods of dynamic programming now
moving ahead we'll discuss when to
implement dynamic programming solution
for any given problem
remember guys you can solve any problem
using dynamic programming which abides
by the properties of dynamic programming
most frequently you will come across the
minimization and maximization problems
which are readily recursive in nature
if you need exhaustive solution for
these problems then you can solve them
using the dynamic programming paradigm
the permutation combination problems can
also be solved using dynamic programming
the problem statement beginning with
find the number of weights are the
famous permutation problems that can be
solved using dynamic programming
approach
i hope that you guys have understood how
dynamic programming works now in the
upcoming sessions we'll discuss some
trickier and famous problems of dynamic
programming so if you have any doubts
about the concept covered in this video
on dynamic programming then let us know
in the comments section below and will
surely help you get them resolved thank
you so much for being here and do watch
out for more videos from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here